حقيقه
في البدايات الاولى كان الخط خط مما يبدو
لي يعني بسيط مثل هذا العلم فرق بين هذا
وبين هذا جدا جدا ولكن انا من خلال بحثي
وحاولت اسال وتوصل لمن قام بخط العلم وجدت
انه من البدايات الاولى
السيد عمر عاصم الحسني من اهل الجموم في
وادي فاطمه في مكه ممن ارتحل من مكه الى
الكويت وحينما زار الملك عبد العزيز
الكويت في 1910 ميلادي كان هو موجود في
الكويت وعين مديرا للمدرسه المباركيه
جدا وخط العلم الكويتي اللي كان باللون
الاحمر وكان يحمل كلمه كويت وهو من اوائل
من خط العلم السعودي بشكله الكوفي وفي
مرحله متقدمه حينما امر الملك عبد العزيز
طيب الله ثراه بافتتاح دار الكسوه في مكه
في عام 1926 عين عبد الرحيم بخاري وهو من
يقوم بكتابه
كل الايات القرانيه في كسوه الكعبه من ذلك
الوقت
فكلف بكتابه الاعلام السعوديه
وتطريزها حتى انه الاشراف على العمليه كما
هو بالعلم اللي امامك عمليه
السنبله اللي كانت موجوده كان يعمل على
تصميمها شارك اخوه لنا
عرب
ومسلمين من باكستان في كتابه البدايه
الاولى للعلم رصدت من رصدي انه في اعلام
طبعت في امريكا بان زيارات الملك عبد
العزيز الى ارامكو كثير منها من امريكا
وخطه من قبل الاخوان اعتقد عرب او
باكستانيين